[Music]
my name is cognate answer I'm Tessa 7
years old I'm the founder and CEO of
boomers information about bicycle
production company boomers is associated
to price that produces bamboo bicycles
and its accessories and we market them
internationally in Europe and North
America we train young people from these
rural areas who would have not had
opportunity of getting for my employment
and then after training we employed them
in this setup each worker receives a
very good wage and Social Security
payments they also have their lunch so
for us what is most important is not
just making products boss to make sure
that it has a very good impact on the
communities last year we shipped over a
thousand two hundred bicycles to zero
Germany has been our biggest export
country and we also have a partner in
Netherlands and it keeps growing
I think that's a good example of a
project where the EU provided some seed
money originally a little bit of money
to encourage the production of bamboo a
sustainable resource and what we've seen
is from those seeds a lot has grown and
I think it's a win-win for Ghana and for
the European Union rock communities are
predominantly poor and is because the
cycle goes on from one generation to the
other
I want to live a legacy where you
empower people to alleviate their own
poverty that you help therefore you
empower them to bring their cycle of
poverty running media from this
[Music]